punkt leuten er hat mich die ganze zeit
gehäkelt oder weniger ich hab's
persönlich überzeugen auch nie nein 1.8
bis zu einem jahr genau
und mit dabei ist er ja ich habe heute
einfach eine neue begrüßung ausprobiert
hat mich ein bisschen von allem von dem
herrn k s creek inspirieren lassen
denn eine wirklich unfall aber so lang
lang halb schon genial gemacht dass ein
bisschen aufwendiger habe jetzt aber so
gemacht
ich hoffe es gefällt euch leute ja ich
spiele halt eine runde joggen mit dr
wie so oft rissel und ich habe 90 die
grünen aufnimmt da spielt natürlich
champions bekannt wird eines upgrades
und wohne ich bin dafür bekannt
ach du bist dafür bekannt also charlie
und ich wollte schon sagen das kommt ihm
entwendet eigentlich aber da es an
lackierter waren krank bin ich allein ja
leute ihr dürft euch den neuigkeiten
eigentlich aussuchen welche neuigkeiten
über die habe ich hab viel für mich
wenn komm mach du einfach mal
stellvertretend hier den neuigkeiten aus
wäre ja also wir haben neuigkeiten zum
tv spot ist es mich auch wir haben
neuigkeit ausbaut zum autounfall
dazu haben auch neuigkeiten und
letztlich haben wir noch neuigkeiten zu
meiner gesichtsbehaarung was jetzt davon
also wozu weniger neuigkeiten ist schon
verlockend aber ich entscheide mich doch
für den tv-spot o ist für den tv spot
bin okay
dann hoffe ich dass wir mit der
entscheidung für den tv spot auch euren
geschmack da draußen getroffen hat hcs
einfach mal ich hab heute so viele
telefonate geführt unter anderem mit dem
regisseur von dem tv spot und also ich
weiß nicht ob ich das erzählen darf
ziemlich sicher dass wir es nicht
erzählen aber dann sollte ich konnte ja
da max band passt immer so ein bisschen
auf dass ich keine scheiße erzähle ich
mit wenig gelassener
so wird das wieder dabei ist die
beleidigung kann sie jetzt nicht sagen
das war lieber jemand wusste ja der
bellen der bänder ist schon der
mastställe aber ja leute wieder ist es
auf jeden fall ein verrücktes konzept
also die hander dinge zusammen gebaut
also wirklich händisch man android
handys gesagt ich hasse dieses wort
manuell zusammengebaut heute trotzdem
zusammen
der arm des manuell zusammengebaut also
gigantische konstrukte irgendwie diese
in diesem werbespot einsetzen wollen und
es wird richtig abgespeist und dann
irgendwie mit einer also für mich das ja
ganz neu so ein dena der lacht
wahrscheinlich wenn ich jetzt erzähle
hier ein werbespot drehen ist was tolles
aber für mich ist etwas neues und
irgendwie mit jetzt da haben wir
telefoniert wegen decker drobe was was
ziehe ich an was was soll ich mitbringen
ist es echt faszinierend für mich und
ich werde auch sehr gerne für euch ein
video machen vom drehtag ich werde mit
einer freundin von mir hinfliegen
vielleicht zeigen das hat jetzt ein
bisschen zu viel aufmerksamkeit bekommen
sollte gar nichts wann das war
es war nicht auf jeden fall nicht so sag
mal so die dame wird auf jeden fall
nicht kostenlos mitgenommen wichtig dass
ich mal sicher ließe wenn wir etwas was
mit geht allerdings auch ihre vitale der
aufrechnung ja ich weiß
merkt zudem die aber angekündigt den
daten durch tatsächlich ab und zu auch
mal was du wartest in milchshake wir
haben an vergleich sogar die haut und so
nice im übrigens hier
da als wir gesehen wie der alte der
hunde ja gut und fresh skills also ich
sag mal durch hat natürlich auch schon
das ein oder andere gerücht
aufgeschnappt in der youtuber szene über
diesen legendären tv spot und ich stehe
natürlich nicht unter vertrag kann ein
paar details raushauen also es wird so
aussehen es wird auf jeden fall eine
nacktszene geben
richtig mir und meiner meiner freundin
also ist es nicht meine feste freundin
aber ist dass eine frau informiert
also mit seiner festen freunde und ich
weiß überhaupt nicht wie sie in dem
video zeigen will ich muss ja auch noch
fragen oder ob überhaupt wiederkommt
schreibt dass man die kommentare ob ihr
das sehen wollt ich begrüße diese
aufnahme ist so endlich einfach seit
dieser begrüßung ich bin einfach raus
das hat mich einfach super und sichert
dass ich jetzt einfach rückwärts springe
der eigentlich als rückwärts geht sogar
egal ist das denn guck mal ich bin
zurück wird nein warum kommt es in
change machen wer also quasi wenn du
herunter fällt also komplett wieder
gefordert der weiter zurück springen
kann
da weiß jeder sprung dann geht die
rechnung geht ja gar nicht mehr ich
wollte mich gerade so spielen aber lass
mir kurz ausprobieren wenn ich jetzt
diesen sprung hier wirklich nicht
schaffen sollte sein bis eine minute vor
schluss
ich bin gerade komplettes gebiet suche
krippenprogramm bei mir leute wie du
bist was ein komplettes gebiet
zurückgesprungen alle ich mache jetzt
noch ein gebiet wo ich war ich wollte
noch ein paar infos zum wahlgebiet
ok so geht das ich bin ich bin runter
gefallen ist bin ich wieder ganz so ganz
form gerade an formaten siebter modul
ich hasse jump n run alter oft alle
mcdonald's burger danke sehr gut werden
bist du dir unterstützen dieser schritt
kann ich natürlich das weiß ich zu
schätzen wenn so ist das so bin ich bei
gott nicht unser feind ich habe ist mein
einziger traum in meinem leben dieses
jump'n'run zu schaffen
also wenn ich hab's doch noch geschafft
das heißt wir müssen von einer
rückwärtslauf change abstand nehmen
vielleicht aber kann man das ja mal eine
1 1 kopie reitet anders da bin ich auch
beim bremer kann sich das aus meiner
sicht bei best building musste jetzt die
entscheidung treffen weißt du was
was schenkt ihr die challenge über sage
dass ich weiß ja gar nicht nehmen wenn
doch ich schenke dir das ist ein
freundschaftliches schüssel angebot von
die kabel war okay natürlich also
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
ob ich so was irgendwie sehen wollt aber
ich wollte noch ein zwei sachen zum
videodreh sagen wie gesagt also sonntag
ich hab's ich sag immer wie gesagt ohne
was gesagt entschuldigung dafür sonntag
fliegen wir morgens dahin
wir drehen sonntag und montag wie gesagt
mit garderobe allem schnickschnack ist
schon eine coole sache ist auch für mich
mal was neues wie sein offizieller
gemacht und wenn nach dem hintergrund
bitte chadwick verfolgt wach lachen sind
doch nicht bei materna die arena lag des
todes bei mir wieso tut mir ging's wie
heißt das server play mini tigers an
ich weiß es nicht wenn aber ich kann
nicht entscheiden ich hatte das kann
schon mal auf denn was ich sag es mal
wie viel ps ich habe live 19 16 14
schlachters 90 nutzen das muss live
vorgelegen
spaces neuen team aber das heißt nicht
dass man gehandicapt in herscheid
wirklich die genau das heißt meister der
handicap nicht aber beschützen darf ich
würde am liebsten und ich kann so nicht
weiter arbeiten
ich glaube ich alle quitten und einen
garten berlin beitrag auf twitter
veröffentlichen
willst du nicht mal irgendwann gegen sie
und kleine urteil von der
geschwindigkeit gekommen wo das gesehen
wer du hast mich gekommen hat gut
gekämpft hat ich weiß aber relativ 0
geschlagen
da wie die jetzt gerade natürlich mal
erzähle es sich alter doch es ist mir
und das ist ich hab dich zu weiter wir
müssen sparen lautet geschrieben das fan
von mir weißt du was in der runde bin
ich hab ihn gefragt wie nie also ich
habe geschrien ich mag da nahm daher
gefragt welcher youtuber spielen habe
ich geschrieben als kate zu mann habe
ich geschrieben ob er mich geil findet
man hat er gesagt hier
oha europameisters lag ziemlich okay
aber wenn ich jetzt voll kaputt man
denkt wahrscheinlich wdr banks deswegen
hat er durch die gas attacke auf mich
weil ich niemals so gute items hätte
nein ich hatte jetzt gilt es die cs
stellen schaffen sich am start die habe
ich auch mal gemacht das war genau das
gleiche ich hatte einfach ein laptop der
geleckt hat wie ein stück scheiße ich
werde es riechen war
was letztlich sehe meinen pc her dass es
auf jeden fall blieb so durch ich lebe
noch mit abgaben halbes herz und noch
was wollte ich eine helle profi nation
irgendein hat mich gerade aus dem leben
heraus genommen
okay ist die leben gekappt hatten kirche
zwar ohne wilsmann ich habe vor allen
dingen
ich muss jetzt mal aufpassen ich glaube
über wien nicht entscheiden
das ist richtig seltsam alte und nowy so
nicht weil ich hab' ich habe zwar ein
leben und ich habe menschen table in
charming table wie ein kollege von mir
früher immer gesagt hat denn ich liebe
grüße dich aber es geht nicht dass man
zweifel braucht also ich habe ihr das
ergebnis war dann ja das ist der bug mit
welcher version spitzen 1.8
ja das ist ein bug da ein bug das ist in
minecraft backwerk als laut 186 spielen
würdest dann hättest du denn nicht in
der 186 ist er behoben aber okay gut
glaube ja aber locker stimmt das nicht
ganz ehrlich und raketen den kommentaren
aber also auf jeden fall sollte diese
informationen nicht stimmen leute habt
ihr von mir die persönliche freigabe die
übelsten beschimpfungen ad dr
die kroatische hätten das stimmt aber
ich bin mir quatsch macht das nicht okay
und werden jetzt alle noch ein leben
zeig was du kannst wo alex lex
letztendlich und du bist punkt leuten
hatten jetzt die ganze hütte driving ja
ich hab's mir wenig überzeugen auch
nähen ein 1.8 du bist zu einem wesen
habe ich jetzt getötet der war nicht nur
bei mir
sein leben durch okay leute was kann ich
euch noch zu berlin sagen für all die
alten geblieben sind ich liebe euch
keine sehr komisch auf der europa league
alle meine informationen ansonsten was
was kann man auch dazu sagen es wird auf
jeden fall abgespeist glaube ich
vielleicht auf dem video vielleicht
vielleicht vielleicht noch ein kleines
fantreffen in berlin auf der station
extraction weil man weiß es nicht aber
wenn was du gesagt kommt dann kommt er
vorbei alles kann also sagen wir dann
gerne offen alexanderplatz das heißt es
keine da gehört das schon so lange geht
deswegen kann ich sagen okay auch
reinmacht gut und in den kommentaren
beleidigen der beschreibung abchecken
okay